hey if you want some exclusive anime
merch like this harem King Deku got a
Smasher mall
checkout enter dream world calm link in
the description hey what is up everybody
its Anna Mack here for anime uproar and
today I will be breaking down one of the
craziest series of events that we've
ever seen in boku no hero this
liberation war arc has been intense
throughout but now it has really kicked
into high gear and so much epic
greatness is happening all at once
Diaby secret confession the fate of
twice and Hawkes the bunny Queens
tireless fight against the high and
normal and endeavors grand entrance Wow
there is so much to talk about so let's
get into it if you enjoyed the boku no
hero content right here on the channel
and you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know it really
helps us and if you happen to be new to
anime or or you just haven't subscribed
yet please consider subscribing and
hitting that notification bell to turn
on all notifications with the way the
YouTube works now you really have to go
through the trouble of clicking the bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a lot of our videos even if
you're subscribed
it's just how YouTube works you can also
hit me up on Twitter and/or Instagram at
anime uproar finally this video will of
course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers I'm talking about the very
latest in the manga the manga is far
ahead of the anime so please proceed
with caution you have been warned
now first of all can we all take a
moment to fully appreciate that colored
miracle cover bruh there are no words to
describe such perfection
anyway staying focused on the story the
chapter starts off with a flashback to
Tokyo me being mentored by Hawks Hawks
reveals to Tokyo me that his greatest
weakness in battle is probably fire
because his feathers can burn up very
quickly since Hawks relies on his
feathers in battle someone who is able
to just burn off all of his feathers
will have a clear advantage
this is definitely a very timely moment
for this flashback Hawkes is solution to
this problem is to just finish the job
as quickly as possible if he is fast
enough to defeat his opponent before the
opponent can attack then the opponent's
quirk won't really matter you can't burn
off Hawks as feathers if Hawkes takes
you out before you have time to use your
quirk but as we've seen from the last
few chapters if you sneak up on Hawkes
while he's dealing with another opponent
you can definitely do a lot of damage
back in the present time fat gum is
using his hilarious and adorable fat
taxi technique to carry toki ami
kaminari mushroom girl and jews ohana
new key all at once inside his massive
belly as I talked about in previous
videos these particular students were
needed on the frontlines because of
their powerful quirks which have long
range abilities and are capable of
taking out many villains at once however
now that they did what they needed to do
the students are being transported back
to safety inside of fat gums fact even
though some of the students are anxious
to stay and help out more fat gum tells
them that they have to leave the rest up
to the adults and that makes sense these
are still just students after all and
they are highly inexperienced when it
comes to fighting actual villains in a
potential battle to the death as awesome
as their quirks certainly are one wrong
move and these young students could be
killed and the pro heroes definitely do
not want that on their conscience and so
it makes sense for the students to be
moved back to the rear and out of harm's
way but just as the students are being
evacuated
Coakley ami sees a massive fiery
explosion blasting out of one of the
windows near the roof of the building
this is the same area of the building
where Hawkes and Dobby are currently
fighting and the explosion was in fact
the result of dobby's deadly blue flames
we see that Hawkes has been injured
badly by dobby his wings and feathers
have been eviscerated his body is burnt
and scarred and he is lying on the
ground seemingly hopeless as
Diaby stomps down on him Dobby laughs
and congratulate Hawkes for successfully
killing twice and instead of being sad
that his comrade was just killed dobby
looks excited and he has an absolutely
maniacal grin on his face hawks can't
believe that twice as death seems to
mean nothing to Dobby Dobby responds by
saying that he can't cry because his
tear glands have been burnt but he is
definitely sad and heartbroken over
twice as death but Dobby certainly
doesn't look heartbroken and he seems
more concerned about the villains losing
the power of twice as quark than losing
twice as a person now maybe Dobby is
just so psychotic that even when he is
genuinely sad he doesn't know how to
show it and he just looks like a
complete maniac but it could also be
that Dobby is so focused on his own
personal mission that he simply does not
care about anything or anyone else
including twice and his other comrades
from the League of villains at this
point the injured Hawks says to Dobby
that he looked into the background of
every league of villains member but
Dhabi and shigaraki were the only to
whom Hawkes could not find any
information on also Hawkes had given up
his real name taka meek a go back when
he was still a little kid he was forced
to say goodbye to that name as soon as
he was recruited into the special hero
program operated by the hero Public
Safety Commission it appears that Hawkes
came from a poor and broken home but
after he displayed an aptitude for
heroism at a young age he was recruited
to become a special kind of hero he went
through intense training that goes far
beyond any regular hero training and he
was expected to strictly follow the
orders of the hero Public Safety
Commission including top secret orders
such as the order to become a double
agent and infiltrate the league of
villains so because Hawkes essentially
stopped being taka Mackay go so long ago
and because he has lived such a
secretive life ever since Hawkes simply
doesn't understand how Dobby could
possibly know his
real name hawks shouts at dobby who the
hell are you and in that moment dobby
finally reveals his secret identity to
hogs unfortunately he doesn't reveal it
to us the readers because the speech
bubble in which he reveals his identity
is blacked out by horikoshi damn [ __ ]
Takashi I can't believe you would do us
like that possibly the single biggest
blue balling in the entire series right
here but what we do know is that Hawkes
is genuinely shocked by Dhabi's
revelation because we can see Hawkes his
face react to whatever it is that dobby
just said dobby then tells hawks that
from the very beginning he should have
been hawks his primary target not
shigaraki twice or anyone else dobby
proclaims that just one man with one
philosophy can shake the world and there
is no such thing as a real hero in this
world dobby then goes on to declare that
he is the ultimate manifestation of
stains will and he says goodbye to hawks
as he prepares to finish the young hero
off before we move on i have to point
out that it is very interesting that
dobby chooses to call himself the
ultimate manifestation of stains will at
this point because it looks to me like
dobby is actually rejecting an important
aspect of stains philosophy you will
recall that stain certainly does believe
that there are real heroes in this world
heroes who are indeed worthy of being
called heroes and all might undec who
were both considered to be such heroes
by stain
stains problem is not with all heroes it
is with those other heroes the ones who
are not worthy but still call themselves
heroes however dobby clearly states that
there is no such thing as a real hero in
this world so even though he claims to
be a manifestation of stains will
dobby's view about heroes actually
differs from stain Dhabi's view of the
hero society is even more extreme and
more cynical than stains the big
question here is how exactly did Dobby
know Hawks is true identity assuming the
Dobby is indeed Toya
Todoroki the eldest son of endeavor and
the brother of short oh is that family
connection enough to explain how Dobby
could know Hawks his real name even as a
child Hawks had been a huge endeavor
fanboy so it is possible that at some
point
Dobby learned Hawks his true identity
through endeavour himself this would
likely have happened at some point
before Dobby decided to abandon his
family and become a villain but I've
seen some comments on my previous MHA
videos and some posts on reddit and
other websites suggesting that there may
be more to Dobby secret identity than
meets the eye
what if Toya Todoroki was also recruited
into the same special hero program that
Hawks was recruited into when both of
them were still children knowing
endeavour he would have probably looked
at such an intensive hero training
program as a great opportunity for his
son to get as strong as possible as
quickly as possible and so perhaps
endeavour decided to pressure Toya into
becoming a special agent of the hero
Public Safety Commission and so what if
at some point during his training or
after his training when he was out on a
mission Toya
aka Dobby was gravely injured and
presumed dead this injury changed
Toya's appearance drastically it burned
his tear glands and many other things
and after everyone assumed that he had
died Toya decided to reinvent himself as
the villain Dobby we all know that
endeavour was a bad father who pushed
his children too hard and short oh and
natsu Oh both resent him for that but as
much of a dick as endeavour has been in
the past I certainly don't think that he
himself would have killed or gravely
injured his own son Toya accidentally or
otherwise don't forget that he wanted
his children to be as strong as possible
and he was willing to do immoral things
to make that happen but there is a big
difference between that and actually one
to kill or seriously deform your own son
and if endeavor had directly caused the
unspecified horrific thing that happened
to Toya chances are that endeavour would
have had to answer for it legally I mean
in any society of laws and especially if
you are considered to be a pro hero
deliberately injuring or even killing
your own son would be a grave crime and
you would have to answer for it
however if endeavor pressured Toya to
join the special hero program in order
to maximize Toya's potential becoming as
strong as possible and if Toya then went
missing on a special hero Public Safety
Commission mission or during some
especially grueling training then Toya's
disappearance would be an indirect
result of endeavours decision to enroll
him into this special program if there
were the case the total rookie family
would still blame endeavour and his
obsession with power for what happened
to Toya but at the same time endeavour
could not be held legally responsible
for any of this and he could continue
being a famous hero in the eyes of the
public at the same time if Toya had been
a part of the special hero program he
would have been more likely to come
across Hawks his real name at some point
since Hawks was also part of the same
program furthermore having been a part
of the special hero program in the past
would give Dobby better reason to behave
the way that he does and to uphold the
ideology that he upholds right now I'm
sure the DA be a cade Toya resents his
father endeavor but his mission and
ideology seems to be about a lot more
than just one person
his father endeavor Shoto and nots will
also feel resentment towards Endeavour
but they don't automatically extend that
resentment to the entire hero society
they certainly blamed their father for
his own faulty actions but they didn't
go on to blame society as a whole for
endeavour being who he is but if Toya
Todoroki had been used and abused not
just by his father but also by the hero
public safety commission through the
special hero program then this would
explain why he would choose to focus his
hatred on the entire hero society
instead of just endeavour
as an individual endeavor was almost
certainly the catalyst but the wider
hero society in the form of the hero
Public Safety Commission also used and
abused Toya and that is what made him
identify on such a personal level with
stains philosophy although as I
mentioned earlier Dhabi's understanding
of stains philosophies seems to be even
more extreme than stains this is the
explanation that I am leaning towards
now Toya wasn't just abused by his
father he was pressured into the special
hero program by Endeavour and he was
then used and abused by the hero Public
Safety Commission as a whole until he
one day disappeared on a mission or
during some particularly intense
training during that mission or training
he was injured probably left for dead
and eventually he resurfaced as the
villain dobby this is just a theoretical
scenario of course but this scenario
makes the most sense to me and it
explains how dobby could have known
about hawks his real name especially
since Hawks abandoned that name way back
when he first joined the special hero
program as a small child I am definitely
not the first person to bring up this
scenario it has been on the internet for
a while but I have to say that this
makes the most sense to me at least
based on the info that we have so far
the last few pages of chapter 2 6-7 show
three very important scenes in the first
scene someone is preparing to activate
Keegan to macchia using the radio which
includes those pre-recorded orders from
all for one and all for one is one of
the few people whose orders gegen to
machia actually obeys this means that
the heroes are about to face their
biggest challenge yet
Keegan to machia is an absolute monster
and he has the ability to level entire
cities once he is unleashed upon the
heroes the situation the battlefield
will shift drastically I've been saying
for weeks now that the hero raid has
been going too smoothly especially the
one at the mansion and some major
complications were bound to come up
giganto macchia definitely counts
a major complication the next scene
shifts back to me to close battle
against the high and normal at least
three of the Nommo are still putting up
a fierce resistance against miracle and
she herself has noticed that her attacks
are not landing like they were just a
little while ago it's not because
miracle is getting tired the bunny queen
has plenty of energy left but it appears
that the nomu are actually getting
stronger it seems that they needed some
time to fully awaken after being
released from those tubes but the more
time goes by the stronger the gnome will
become Madoka decides that she has to
stop fighting the Nomo and complete her
primary mission which is to take out dr.
Yugi co and shigaraki she uses her
incredible quirk to ditch the nomu and
catch up to the doctor at the other end
of the lab however the nomu seem to be
getting faster as well and medico is not
quite able to escape the clutches of
their weird tentacles and other pointy
things that they are able to extend from
their bodies as she struggles to break
free from the grip of the high-end
gnome-o-meter quo is determined to take
out her main targets at all cost
Madoka vows to eliminate the doctor and
she got a key before the nomal are able
to eliminate her she storms into the
section of the lab within which you
Chico and she Guara keys to bar hiding
and Fujiko absolutely loses it once
again as soon as he sees her Fujiko
seems paralyzed by shock and fear
boogers are like oozing out of his nose
and this is like the fourth time that he
has been forced to react this way since
the raid on the hospital started I can't
really blame him though no one would
ever want to be on miracles bad side
meanwhile at the mansion
Takayama emerges from the safety of fat
gums belly and activates dark shadow in
an attempt to save hogs while back at
the hospital endeavour finally smashes
his way into the secret lab and
absolutely wrecks one of the high-end
nomu beneath his fiery fist miracle is
injured part of her right
rabbit ear has been torn off but she
seems to have survived thanks to
endeavors epic entrance I am assuming
that endeavor showed up in time to save
her because we don't actually see the
full extent of the damage that miracle
has suffered
we are only shown the upper part of her
head and the fact that her ear has been
damaged
I certainly hope that she survived
because I freaking love her and I refuse
to even consider any other possibility
and that is how this absolutely insane
an action-packed chapter ends and wow
what a chapter we had the incredible
showdown between dobby and hawks in
which dobby revealed his secret identity
to hawks although sadly he did not
reveal it to us
the readers we also had Takayama joining
the fight in order to save his mentor
Hawks but Toki ami is still just a you a
student and dobby is a ruthless
overpowered villain this decision to
abandon fat gums belly and face off
against dobby may cost
Takayama dearly in the very near future
in this incredible chapter we also got
to see more miracle greatness including
yet more evidence of her unbelievable
courage and resolve in the face of
impossible odds she is willing to
sacrifice her life for her mission and
she is already one of my favorite pro
heroes and MHA characters of all time
what a hero and what a woman on top of
that endeavor has finally made his way
to the secret lab and the number one pro
hero is about to get his chance to face
off against the high and no mu and
eventually probably against shigaraki
himself and finally as if all of that
wasn't enough it appears that gegen
Tamaki a' is about to be activated which
means that the heroes are in for a world
of hurt this was truly a classic action
packed shown in chapter and this is yet
more proof that this boku no hero war
arc has the potential to become the
greatest arc in the entire series this
chapter was just so epic and so
entertaining and if this arc continues
to deliver such amazing
afters in the future then I have no
doubt that this will shape up to be the
best arc in the entire series so far let
me know what you guys think how exactly
the dobby come to know Hawks is real
name and what did he just reveal to
Hawks
inside that darkened speech bubble also
how do you think Tommy's decision to try
and save Hawks will play out will he
succeed or is dobby about to make taco
eme regret his decision and what about
gig on Tamaki a-- how is his involvement
going to change the situation on the
ground at the mansion finally how
freaking amazing is miracle and what did
you think about endeavours epic entrance
is miracle going to survive now that
endeavor has finally appeared or are her
many injuries going to get the best of
her in the end I certainly hope miracle
survives I love her so much as a
character and as a top-tier waifu but i
look forward to hearing your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more please leave a like to let me know
it really does help and if you happen to
be new to anime uproar or you just
haven't subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter and or instagram at anime uproar
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for supporting
our work and making these videos
possible special thank you to baby r a
disciple of Lord to Eagle himself
another big thank you to all of our the
one tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including in grata alone
an atom the world stealers the school
bus Tyson quit Ino acquired respect and
part a heffa and I can't forget our pro
hero to your patrons including the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings L drous Anatoly
Kazansky on hell Cruz team Sparky 65
Rohan Kapoor cricket XP Ted no Ted
Salter Joe's Stanton very gucci alicia
octor animal is 69 jessica calif on
emperor otaku JCC waka
and the coach if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value for
you please consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]